[Applause]
as soon as the basketball's coming out
he comes out here and wants to play
basketball so I come up to him on my car
you said you were sick he said don't
don't pray for like that I said I'm a
teacher I can approach you how I want to
take it I didn't do this particularly I
just asked it a question and then I I
try to go over here he goes over here
and I try to walk him outside to get him
one and he's got the basketball and it
comes to me I grab the basketball and
then he sort of bucks on me and comes at
me into my face
and he won't talk to me and he says
you're a racist motherfucker and I'll
kick your fucking ass Katie
but I want to have a conversation in
front of you with him because he got to
know if he's wrong
because
the administrator is my counselor
whoever came High the pizza Institute my
Institute I've been taking all four
years
old
so with that being said my God put me in
here okay not knowing that I told him I
wasn't feeling good came and came to him
about that that was already done today
cool we cool I'm up there in the
bleaching sitting down finally when I
come come down from off the bleaches you
want to come at me aggressively what
happened to you you supposed to be in
the bleachers like that's not how you
talk to me you could be a good citizen
but be aware when you talking to me it's
respect
so what happened after that after that
it went it wasn't nothing else to say I
walked out for Casino what I was doing
I'm not gonna talk to a good old citizen
you could have your love you know you
feel me if that's not gonna resolve
nothing if I'm not doing nothing if I'm
minding my own business don't come to me
no type of way now how you bumped up
against me like that we're talking about
as a teacher he didn't plan
all right
I said okay that's fine next thing you
know the basketballs come out and now
you're on the floor so I came up you
know I was like I thought you were sick
when we're playing kickball now you're
not sick anymore and that's when you you
went from here like that and you shut it
down and I couldn't talk to you and
that's where we are
I asked you a question I said I thought
you were sick we were playing kickball
and then you went and you changed two
phones like I was coming at you I think
you said don't come at me like that I
was like ask me a question I'm not
coming at you
if I came at you you know it but I'm not
gonna do that I'm 50 years old I'm too
old with that stuff okay I've done I've
been doing this for 26 freaking years
all right it's got a little bit
experience so you think I'm coming at
you totally wrong 100 but as a teacher
and as a person of uh respect that I do
respect these kids you asking the kids
in here can you call me racist I'm the
most least racist person in the school
you guys anybody around here quiet
quieter and different kids young kids
adults I guarantee you I treat this man
this man this man the same effect they
treat me the Oklahoma wrenches
hesitation you're my students I ask you
a question and you could not answer me
yeah really upset
that's exactly what I did from the
moment I came in this class
what what's the question with regarding
to why why it is why that and I gave you
a simple question in return but you
wanted to go further with the um
I'll let you talk I'll let you say what
you had to say what you said over there
supposedly that's not what you said you
handed me aggressively and I said I'm
talking in the phone
you still had your voice raise while I'm
telling you trying to explain to me like
why I came down from the bleacher
but you still had your voice up see this
is why my boy's gonna stay This Tall
because I'ma show you how you was doing
me right there I wouldn't keep my tongue
like this I ask you a question I'm like
why are you not sick now it don't matter
I gave you I'm not arguing and you still
kept coming at me aggressive and I let
it go and I walked off running my own
business as I was doing and then I
walked up there on the bleachers and sat
down the reason why you asked me while I
was out on the bleach to begin with
right minding my own business once again
so why are you coming at me aggressive
okay that's not a question
I'm a pea teacher our two classes are
playing a kickball game against each
other coach Marley versus I look up and
you're in the places I don't got nothing
to do with me feeling sick
didn't know you were sick at that time
that's why I asked you the question I'm
like I'm like why are you in the butcher
how many times I got to tell you okay
okay I think the thing is is you were
sick but then when he allowed you guys
to have free time and then you decided
you're right and wanted to play not that
I decided but at the time when I was up
feeling myself I'm gonna come down and
I'm gonna interrail is that a problem it
was designed a lesson yeah
a lesson a lesson is not to go out there
and play with students just because this
is a physical education
the problem is our kickball game we were
playing against the point it's not about
the kickball game it's about me not
feeling myself how many times I gotta
say that I didn't say a word to you
about not playing did I say anything
that's like that's fine you came to me
after after I came down on the bleachers
that's my whole point you keep talking
about them
talking about the game
[Applause]
lower your voice lower your voice
I'm just cruising myself anything else
you wanna come from if you want to talk
to anybody I I got a lawyer anything but
you're not going to come in no type of
way and disrespect get your hands off me
hold on get your hands off of me I said
hold on you got five seconds to get
yourself what the fuck are you gonna do
you got five seconds what you gonna do
you got five six
off of me and get on my presents like
you got some sense be a good citizen
like you is how about you be a good
citizen not raise your voice that badge
on your hook and causing a big scene
inside the gym nah because I'm really
pushing for disorderly condo I ain't
pushing that
all right
like I said
okay
[Applause]
come on man get your stuff let's go
because
even Mr Perry wants you to get you stuff
because he wants you to meet him over
there so let's go I don't care about
what Mr Perry says I'm in this class I
just got in this class what you say to
me
come on man you finna take a ride to
jail dude I ain't fucking with you
let's go
[Applause]
get up off the bleacher that's fine you
can record all you want I've been
recording the whole time
that's cool
got everything gotta say it in there too
so let's go
come with me
[Applause]
stand up and come with me
stand up and come with me
I'm telling you to stand up and come
with me for causing the disorder inside
the gym in front of everybody else
you don't need to be in here Mr Perry's
telling you to come out I'm telling you
to come on so you need to get up and
come on
I'm giving him a lawful order to get up
and come on now
all right man take the backpack off we
finna go to the gym don't resist me dude
[Applause]
what's wrong
[Music]
thank you
this cameras is still all right
time
everybody else
good for Christmas
please
thank you
[Applause]
baby
guys hey can we get them
in the old gym
because you're not listening to the
lawful order that I'm giving you take
the bag off you're still holding me why
is y'all still only at this friend is
why my parents wouldn't be called
listening
take the bag off why are you trying to
get me to retain my stuff off of me this
is my this is my property this is me I'm
not trying to steal it I'm trying I
don't care you just detain you in
handcuffs throw me around because you
didn't listen I told you to get up I
didn't feel right
to be treated the way you treated me
why'd you still holding me I've been
told you to give me a second
you keep do you not do you not
understand that when I say give me a
second that means move remove yourself
away from behind remove yourself away
from me every time I get you a second
you don't take your back away from me
I will let you go
remove yourself away from me and I will
let you go if you take this back will
you remove yourself away from me
I just told you what I would do take the
bag off take it off
take the bag off
take the bag off it
take it off
you're going to jail for just sort of
conduct resisting at this point take the
bag off
no I'm not good I literally just got
thrown around by the police I haven't
done anything they simply called called
the administrators down here which is
the teacher that um that our man for
physical education like he called the
administrators down knowing I didn't
have no wrong I was doing it no wrong
I simply came to him and when he asked
me a question which on why am I at the
beaches I told him I wasn't feeling good
I exit the bleachers when I started
feeling myself and he wanted to come in
here aggressive so he got a a police
officer down here pulling on my locks
Landing into the um bleacher's life
I like I had no
I'm at the school and they still they
still would they would not let me go
tell me when I get up there
all right take the bag off I'm not doing
nothing take the bag off nothing is
going to happen get up here you are
fixed to get put in haircuts one way or
another night take the bag off
take it off
take the bag off
take the bag off you're refusing a
lawful order for me to be able to put
you in handcuffs take the bag off
take the bag off
take it off
take the bag off
take it off
take the bag off
take the bag off
I'm going to take the bag off we can get
you decontaminated once the backpack is
off
take the bag off
take it off
I know it sucks if you would have just
listened this couldn't this wouldn't
have happened that's all that's all you
had to do was listen
you're still going to resist
do you want it some more dude because I
that's fine I got a whole can
take the bag off man that's all you have
to do is take the bag up
take the bag off
I told you to take the bag off
that's fine dude
take the back off take it off
I can't breathe
if you take the bag off we'll get you
decontaminated
that's all it is
unfortunately
I can't breathe
[Music]
give me your hand man
that's great
give me a nurse up here
let's roll over man
roll over
roll over
roll over
roll over and sit up
roll over and sit up
getting breathe
okay free
roll over and sit up dude
roll over roll over and sit up dude
foreign
I'm trying to help you
roll over and sit up
roll over and sit up
well Lindsay stood up that's what I'm
trying to get you to do
all right
let go of the bag dude
you got a nurse here to help you we got
it with the spray okay so can we get you
into the bathroom and get you to start
flushing your eyes out because that's
the only thing that's going to help that
spray okay yeah
foreign
let go of the backpack
I'm sorry
bro
the more you struggling against him the
harder it is just let go of the bag
apply this would be over a lot quicker
that's what we all want
just let go of the bag
we're not taking your stuff
it ain't about myself it's not about you
taking it that's not the point
because you're not listening you're
resisting me
so give me the stuff give me your head
even if I'm minding my own business and
I kept telling you to let go of me
you dude still out and just give me your
hand I'm not doing it nothing
I'm literally not even defending myself
I didn't put my hands on you I'm not
doing anything
I literally stayed content I stayed calm
I kept my mouth closed at some point it
is not no right for you to let slam me
against the bleachers
and pulling my locks I absolutely didn't
do anything
no I kept telling you to do on the phone
on top of that I didn't I wasn't even
acknowledging you at that point you
sprayed me in the face well I can't tell
you to give me your hands give me the
bag and everything else I had a right to
call my
let's stand up and go to the bathroom so
we can flush your eyes come on
I'll help you out can you let it go and
be I can get myself up
one two three you do not make me feel
safe I say I said one two three stand up
and you remove yourself from me so I can
get myself together
that's not how this works man come on
stand up
so what
come on
stand up one two three let's go
come on man
do you want to get your eyes flushed out
let's go hey come on man
okay do you want the nurse to help you
up
because she's standing right here would
you like her to help you
do you want the nurse to help you
[Music]
I'm trying to help you stand up so we
can go to the bathroom I never about you
I never resisted
away from me
just let go of you can we help you stand
up and get you to the restroom to flush
your eyes out okay
the reason it's hard to breathe is
because you've inhaled some of that
pepper spray okay that's going to ease
up eventually but we need to flush your
eyes out that's the only way it's going
to get out of your eyes your eyes are
going to continue to burn
okay so can we calmly get you into a
restroom to flush your eyes out
can you do that for me okay
servant Ray has let go of you and he has
stepped away but he is still here
situation okay
that would notice
I just want to make sure you're okay so
in order to get your eyes flush we need
to get you into a restroom and start
splashing put water on your eyes to
flush all that irritant out
here
I'm not sure that he will
matter
of the story yeah
260.
everybody
start my card for
just over the conduct
also advise
201 or 200
. I've got one pepper sprayed at
Easter's Hospital
in your car
Mr Fuzzy street it's just a standby the
kid has called his dad his dad's irate
so the dad may end up coming to the
school
we need to get his eyes decontaminated
we need to get his eyes flushed out
can we walk you into the restroom
there's one right down the stairs
I have to be here at this point
unfortunately
I think
my mouth closing
he didn't have no right
to physically take me in any type of way
okay but right now we want to clean your
eyes
I can't control that okay but what I can
help you
get your eyes closed
is to get you in the restrooms
okay the breathing will eat up okay but
your eyes is going to take some time
I'm in the new gym with the students
they're still refusing to stand up and
refusing to go get decontaminated
but the dad will probably try to enter
through the front office
this is correct for next
she's still doing okay I don't know if
she's going to go back to class but she
kind of reminders sometimes that's why I
made the comment about having a fast one
so yeah just make sure she's okay she
probably is daddy's life I'm sorry the
dad is Alexander Sledge
father's name is gonna be Alexander
Sledge
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you're gonna have to stand up eventually
come on man
of course there's a bunch of recordings
and people taking pictures and stuff
that was in the gym too as far as the
kids yeah so it's just about to go viral
as I say
I got them
okay
that's correct the kids just sitting
here you won't stand up and you don't
get hit with him now
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I'm just trying to get in the stop so I
could talk to him and resolve this
situation
but then he wants to fuck up with me
at that point
telling me I got five seconds to take my
hands off of it now you're making me
feel like you're about to assault me
oh
do they make me feel comfortable that's
the reason why and that's and that's
fine
thank you you could have voiced and said
that but instead oh you said was you
have five seconds to get your hands off
me
comfortable
okay I told you that multiple times so
police officers do have the right to
give you directions I I have the right
to do the directions in the school
that's correct
I'm clear
they'll just raise me in my face
I gave you multiple multiple times too
to take the backpack off to put your
hands behind your back
I gave you multiple chances
hey give me a chance if you literally
hugging me with your hands on me you was
not making me feel like any comfortable
this kid in one of the teachers down
here drawing back and forth and stuff
like that he got the raising his voice
disrupting the entire gym full of people
that's even playing basketball he goes
the walkway I did this I was like hey
hold up just a second man yeah he looks
at me and says you got five seconds take
your hands off me I was like okay
follow him over here because at this
point he's he's mine
he says I'm a bleacher I tell him get up
man you know you got to go with me Mr
Perry once you get up and get your stuff
you got to go with me no screw you not
doing that so I'll go grab his arm and
the fight again and while we're up here
I'm pushing to the ground I'm trying to
get his backpack off of him not give him
a chance to take it off himself and
everything else I kept telling him take
her backpack off put your lines her back
back you know back and forth same thing
he wouldn't so I sprayed him to see if
he would
listen to pain compliance still yet
he is still not
complying that looks like that is right
here is the door
um
just sit down dude just sit down you
have you haven't made a properly
decontaminated yet which is what we need
to do
okay
is this your dad I guess he is
he okay for now
are you his dad sir I'm sorry can I
speak to you out here please
so the situation is
your son and a coach
are mad at each other for whatever
reason I'm just there to be seen and try
to keep the peace for whatever reason
well your son starts getting more
agitated and watch that erasing his
voice disrupting the entire gym
at this point that's just sort of
conduct but I'm not really want to do
anything with at this point
but he goes to walk away and one of my
things that I try to do here with all
the kids is try to pull them to the side
after they've had a confrontation with a
teacher and go
let me holler at you real quick let me
talk to you try to squash whatever this
is that you got going on so as he walks
away I put my hand on the shoulders hey
man come here let me talk to you for a
second he squares off with me and says
you got five seconds get your hands off
I was like really like at that point now
I'm feeling Britain because you're
squaring up on me well why are you doing
this As She's Walking Away I was like
look dude come here I need to talk to
you if you're causing a huge senior
yelling you're causing disrupt the
entire gym you go sit down with
bleachers I said look even Mr Perry
wants you to get your stuff you at least
got to go to in-school suspension or
whatever he wants to do with you for now
I said but get your stuff come on get up
go up butt
it keeps no yeah
and so you got to take a rapping this
story he calls this big suit
I'm okay you can open it
um at this point you got a rabbit who
calls this big freaking scene everything
else so okay I'm buying somewhere to go
to stand him up and he starts fighting
so I'm using everything I can to not
tumble down the bleachers with you do I
grab his hair yeah I do because I'm just
I'm grabbing for whatever I can to try
to get a hold of him to trying to tame
him and get him a handcuffs as
peacefully as I can but he's not wanting
me to do that and then I'm trying to
take the backpack off of it I'll tell
you hey man take the back I'm not trying
to steal your stuff it's going to go
with you but I to in order for me to
detain you without any further incidents
I need you to take the backpack off and
I let him go I let him try to do it
himself he doesn't want to so grab it
again try to help him get it off and
it's back and forth back and forth I
keep giving him verbal commands I'm
giving you a law for work take a
backpack off I gotta detail you so on
and so forth go doesn't listen so for my
policy if people are still not listening
even after I've already tried soft and
hard hand control I my next step is to
go to some form of
you know baton taser pepper spray I
don't want to tase the kid I'm not
trying to hit him all the time so I use
the most
compliant
course I can which is the paper spray
which usually helps kind of lighten that
mood and then go oh shit that hurts all
right fuck this I'm done
I didn't want to put electricity to the
kid's body he's just a kid I didn't want
to have to use this damn thing so that's
why I use a pepper spray and he's still
I'm like trying to get him to take his
backpack off so I'm getting cuffed up
and we can take him go get him
decontaminated and he's still not
listening to me still resistant still
trying to keep the backpack on still
don't want to stand up I'm like dude
at what point are you going to listen to
me so we can get this over with
you know and I understand he's calling
you understand you're pissed because
you're here everything's inside and this
was recorded before I even started
talking to him so if you do want to
capture the or get a hold of the body
cam you're more than welcome to I'm sure
the sheriff's office will be able to
supply for your logger whoever
um and then sell from there um but and I
was trying to be as nice as I could be
from the get-go with him but he just he
wouldn't let me it's he just wouldn't
let me
anybody
Witnesses yeah so the coaches witnessed
it the teachers here not this tall black
gentleman but the Mr Perry Mr Grimm the
coaches and of course a bunch of kids
they're in the middle of the altercation
started pulling their phones and stuff
out but I mean they're going to catch
whatever they can on their phone
all the good stuff but all the teachers
and the Mr Graham and Mr Perry caught
from the beginning
we don't have one of them step out
yes sir
would you mind stuff
hey I'm Glenn Perry
so it's my understanding that at the
beginning of class I guess that there's
some genders usually prepared when I
send usually some sort of a structured
game and then they have a free gym the
Taurus had told the the coach that you
know he didn't feel good he didn't want
to participate folks let him save the
villagers during when it became open gym
the Taurus went to pissed me the coach
was like I thought you said you were
sick well you know it's you don't get to
do the fun stuff if you can't do the
other stuff too I guess you know I did
not witness there any cars
aggressively you know coach said he
didn't he was just questioning and you
know he doesn't have the right to you
know ask like hey why aren't you
explaining the lessons
um any cars did call him a racist and
did use profanity towards him and that's
what he called you know to the front
office
um coach Graham and officer McRae were
the first people that came up and then I
came in after that
trying to talk to them try you know you
know the cars really wanted to listen to
the coach under the coaches really you
know there but that so we asked Horus to
come out of the gym you know he refused
hey I'm at school
also too during the screaming match
between the coach and your son I did
tell your son because his voice was
elevating really high hey man keep it
down
so he refused to come out
you know I asked him again officer gray
gave him the directive you know to come
with them and also a great trying to you
know
pick him up kind of good by the arm and
pull him out Taurus resisted and it just
you know got an increasingly more
volatile from there
after school I had a genome uh genetics
the gymnasium
yeah
missing a bit
yeah
I'm talking to the uh
coach Barry how many this is assistant
principal and uh the uh officer ISO
officer
okay
no you're fine
um
so he's just you know I like to coach
where's the coach he's he was down he
may be in my classroom with the other
students we removed the other students
from the gym you know it's
that's matter too I mean I didn't want
it to go this way all I want to do is
talk to him about look man if you if
you're having an issue and I've told all
the students this that I've interacted
with we have an issue with the teacher
who you're getting pissed off
and if you walk out come find me let's
talk I'll help you calm down and you
know we can talk with a teacher and see
if we can come up with some kind of
conflict or something
all the kids you know I've got on a zoom
call with all the kids in the entire
school and told them that
on a zoom call
so I mean they all know that if you're
having an issue with something just come
and talk to me and I'm sure we can
figure out a way to solve the issue even
if it's with you and a teacher
's Travis were you here
when the when the whole tester started
yes
and how did that happen
so I asked him to come out of the gym he
refused me you know officer McRae asked
him to come with him or to come out with
us you know he refused
um you know I'm a great said I'm gonna
give you a lawful order you know told
him you know this this is what I'm doing
you know Taurus I'm not going with you
you know I'm just going to sit here
um you know some regret he tried to like
gotta make him laugh and he resisted and
fell over and foreign
already filming everything within School
um
the last incident that happened
it never showed up before anything
no that's fine
oh yeah I mean there's cameras and
everything I definitely like to get a
hold of it she said I could go to the
shows off here yeah so the the body cam
whenever I dock it tonight it'll
download and the sheriff's office will
be able to get a hold of it tomorrow so
probably we would be ready for you or a
lawyer or whatever it should be able to
retained by at least Thursday
probably just a couple hours just enough
to get him booked in getting my bond if
they do that there I'm not real sure and
then you guys about to come pick him up
um but I need to get him decontaminated
from the spray but he's not going to
listen to me he's not going to stand up
he's not wanting to take the backpack
off he's not wanting to do anything that
I'm trying to ask him to do to
contamination yeah wash his eyes out
from the pepper spray
uh can I talk to him absolutely if if
you think it was sitting right here
Dad you want to talk to him first and
see what you can do if you don't mind
can I just have Dad talk to him first
real quick thank you
you get his eyes wiped off with the
paper towels
so we can get you again
where is it you're going to wash his ass
yeah is there a bathroom that we can use
okay
you want your dad to help you walk man
that way you can not fall down the
stairs
foreign
right here sir to your uh right this
first door right here
let's see if it's unlocked
this thing I've never been in here so
I'm not sure exactly where the sink is
in here
[Music]
listening
so we don't do the wrong your eyes
okay
I told you up there I'm here to help you
out brother you got to let me help you
out okay
let me help you out
no I couldn't bend over
here's the sink right here set your
hands out
I'm fixing to get a hole while watching
not rub your eyes you hear me don't rub
your eyes
and I tell you though when she don't
bring your eyes out
anything else
I didn't have to go like this
is that all of them
you got them open
[Music]
supposed to do
all right
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
we need help now
no this this kid's about to take a ride
to juvenile
uh I couldn't stand in one of these
trips guys you guys need
okay all right
and apparently a fight over there yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
Johnson Johnson's baby's off the bed
[Music]
um
uh today it's Gilmore
I'm not sure
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I think I'll be okay now
um but
I'm uh I'm about to 425 distributor
all right
foreign
[Music]
are you clearing all my shit I got going
on over here
okay
uh while I was dealing with this kid
there another girl fight happen up front
East Ridge is helping me take care of
that up there but I'm fixing 425 fish
kid
um it started off if you want me to
explain to you the situation now or I
can wait till you get here got better
either way
whenever we walk out the doors here it's
like right there
um so this kid and one of the coaches
was having an issue with each other they
called admin and me in here I'm standing
by letting them resolve their conflict
this kid starts yelling starts getting
agitated I tell them hey man lower your
voice calm down so on and so forth and
the kid was wanting to walk away and I
was letting them off away but I just
kind of put my hand on their shoulder
that's even starting okay like hey hold
up let me talk to you for a minute to
try and help resolve the conflict and
the kid squares up on me and says you
got five seconds to take your fucking
hand off me
okay here we go with this so I'm walking
with him he's still yelling he's still
going on and on and on I'll tell him
keep your voice down you're causing
disorder he goes and sits down Mr Perry
tells him how you need to you know come
down here and I'm telling him at this
point because he's just still yelling
and everything else I was like all right
dude you got to go with me I'm getting
lost order stand up
and you're going to be detained and
you're going to get hooked for this
early condo he keeps resisting me
so I go to grab him stand him up and the
fight's on
we're hand to hand fighting trying to
get a hold of him I grab his dreads pull
them down the ground trying to get a
hold of him keep trying to push him to
the ground put him in cuffs
still not listening I'm trying to get
his backpack off of him to put him
because not listening he told me to let
him go I let him go let him try to take
the backpack off Still's not listening I
grabbed that happens three times finally
let him go he's like recording calling
people and everything else I'll tell him
take the backpack off put your hand
linger back you're under arrest at this
point for this over the conductor
resisting arrest
he doesn't want to listen so I'll spray
him
and still dance they were not listening
so his dad comes here his dad finally
helps him get
calm down and we East Ridge is here they
helped me get him to contaminated and
everything so now he's fixing to take a
ride
so
it
[Music]
so it
yeah I'm fine I'm just trying to
no I mean I'm this is about to be viral
because there's like 50 kids in the damn
gym that whenever we started fighting
it's our pictures and videos and all
that shit too so
yeah the new gym in the back
and then during all this two girls got
to fight in the front so they're these
were just helping me deal with that
so
me and the the dean of students was and
then right behind us was Mr Perry so all
three of us was with him and a coach him
the coach we're trying to let them talk
and they keep talking over each other
they're both getting a little agitated
well the kid starts getting even more
agitated and tense and up and everything
else so I'll tell the kid I'm like hey
yo blow your voice you're making this
thing inside the gym pretty much Pretty
much telling them look you're causing a
disorder
and he doesn't stop doing that he walks
trying to walk away and at this point
I'm wanting to stop him and talk to him
to get him to calm down before putting
him in handcuffs
correct
the entire gym
and so I stopped him to try and get him
to calm down before this disorder keeps
going into so I could talk to him before
handcuffs went on and whenever I just
tried to stop him he squares up with me
and said you got five seconds to get
your fucking hand off me
and I was like all right so you're at
that point my mind was made up he was
going with me because
you've already caused a disorder and now
you're swearing up on me saying I got
five seconds to get my hand off you and
all I'm trying to do is prevent you from
going to jail
and then I'm falling off the bleachers I
got to put him in cuffs after I told him
he's been up several times during the
lawful orders said that over the body
cam giving you a lawful order to stand
up didn't want to listen I grabbed him
to stand him up in the fight starts and
I'm grabbing him trying to throw him
down end up grabbing his threads jerking
him down on the bleachers
and then the rest of what I told you is
you know backpack not want to take it
off giving three different chances to
take it off still wouldn't take it off
so instead of going Hands-On with him
again I spray him
which is the next step and
here's a force
so
and then he just sat down and wouldn't
listen and bad finally got here because
Dad was pissed off screaming over the
phone I explained to Dad when he got
here what was going on Dad calmed down
and then helped me get his kid calm down
enough to go in here and get him
decontaminated
no no the Gym's fine
it was just a one quick burst just
it wasn't like a full can or nothing
all right
all right then
my service here and Anthony
I thought he was outside
just out front
and I was like all right His Radio
started to go off he's like I gotta go I
was like all right see you man yeah I
went and got a thing of ice for the car
and
hello
[Music]
so I don't know I don't know what
optional phrase or Deputy mcgrace side
of the story for the teacher's side of
the story is and so I can't comment on
anything today
I was trying to help help the young
brother out you know squared away and he
was refused to help let me help him out
okay
once you got here he decided he wants to
stand up and get him in here
you know this is uncomfortable in this
situation before it got further with him
putting this hands on me well and
anything
yeah
[Music]
he's trying to come in here and help you
out okay yeah I'm not talking about that
I was already situation with myself
let's step back outside
there's an echo in here it's quite work
for your dad to hear on the phone we
were talking yeah so let's step up here
okay
he is still he's with his other class
right now also he will make sure
at this point with everything happening
like I told you you gotta take a ride
[Music]
so
at this point man anything you want me
to take with you I mean you wanna give
them your phone or anything go ahead and
get them yeah for sure because I don't
want him to leave that down there chain
bracelet
s
all right
with this one I need you to put your
hands on your back man
hey he shoot he should be able to call
you from down there as well and let you
know whenever they're ready for him to
leave like I said I'm more familiar with
you know taking her adults to jail and
then getting a bond and all that stuff
as far as once he gets pipe worked on
they're gonna take them in there they're
gonna process them probably within a
couple two or three hours they'll call
you up
yeah as long as it'll help keep you calm
yeah I'm good with that
all right man you put in your handsome
you don't make me feel safer than what I
what I feel I get it so turn around I
gotta put you here behind your back
we'll catch it up okay
let's put your hands together like
you're praying
like that right there okay it's gonna be
a little bit more comfortable area
I had my mouth closed I told them
both when I needed this boat I saved
minding my business like I was smarter
people here
I'm only holding on to you that way you
don't fall
and catch yourself with your hands
behind your back
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
I gotta start my car
there's not air that usually goes back
there but I'll roll the window down
we're gonna get on the passenger side
right here
go and have a seat okay
yeah
off Holly Street
Holly
yeah right off East Third Street
all right go down Third Street lean back
just a little bit for me okay the best
you can I gotta both you up someone stay
safe I'm gonna get this car on and get
the window down
hey y'all might sit with him real quick
I gotta get my computer out of my office
up there
[Applause]
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
all right
foreign
foreign